Mr. Licht, do you think that
humans are going to attack us elves? It
's just a rumor, but it's
not a story.
That's why, even though each person's magical power is weak, the numbers are increasing and they're getting on top of things. In the
past, from natural disasters to the ward administration, which was often helped by
us elves.  I'm afraid because I don't know about it
even though it's there.Both are people who can be given this power,
Grimwar.We should be able to understand each other
.
[Music]
Oh, oh, oh
, there's another one from that functional mouth
Sword magic
[Music]
Light envelop with medicine
The day of
Abi's attack  Wizard
light magic 5 are
you okay